starfleet command yes sir i don't think
you could possibly imagine
that uh a television show could have
this much impact on on so many people
for so long but it's wonderful what is
it lieutenant malfunction sir i have had
letters and come in contact with young
women
who
have said to me you came on and i
thought my god there's somebody there
representing me
in 1966 a black woman starring in a
primetime role with a diverse cast was
truly groundbreaking and proving just
how much representation matters we spoke
with siniqua martin greene who more than
50 years later calls the shots as the
captain on star trek discovery must be
astronomical the amount of energy
required to maintain that the very first
time i met her she came to the premiere
of star trek discovery and she whispered
to me
take care
it's yours now
it really propelled me forward
it's like it's what i needed to hear
from her specifically because i'm here
because of her
the skies are green and glowing
but michelle almost walked away from
star trek following season one after
being offered a role on broadway a very
famous fan changed her mind i turned
around straight into the face of dr
martin luther king
and nearly fainted
he admired the show and told me how much
he admired my work and how important it
was
on television and i said well thank you
very much but i'm leaving the show and
dr king said you cannot you have changed
the face of television forever he said
it's more important that people who are
not black see this show see you in this
role
because they see us for the first time
as we should be seen as equals captain
receiving messages from her ground
station
how do you think she paved the way for
so many of us well
what gets me about her is is the service
and the complete setting down of self
and when dr king said no no no no we
have to see you we've never seen this
before we need you she said okay she put
down herself yeah and dedicated the rest
of her career to our progression now
there's a 20th century enterprise this
would require the services of people
with a variety of skills and
qualifications
michelle's impact went far beyond
hollywood it was under contract to nasa
to recruit the women and
minority astronauts for the space
shuttle program and i developed others
aerospace educational programs and
projects
for
various agencies this is your massive
when she went to nasa and said there
needs to be more color here what are you
guys doing they said oh yeah absolutely
but can you bring them in though
what did it really take for her to do
that you know and and she did it
selflessly today miss nichols is 89
years old in 2015 i was honored to visit
her at her la home how does that make
you feel when you hear them say to you
i looked to you
and what you did on television and it
inspired me when we went on tv
i was very proud it was the first
interracial
show
that was important
she had recently suffered a stroke but
her spirit was strong and feisty i have
this thing about
so-called sickness
and
i can't say it about everything every
sickness but i i've always felt a little
girl
if you deny it it'll go away and it does
you're a fighter yeah oh yeah i'm a
fighter
i'm
i'm this kind of
fighter what do you think ultimately her
legacy is
well i think she's a hero
yeah you know yeah we throw that word
around a lot
yeah but she really is one
in real life
and that's her legacy it's her heroism
you know and the impact from it
because she changed the world
[Music]
you